this was a struggle of Cuban Patriots
against a Cuban dictator on March 13
1962 The Joint Chiefs of Staff put this
document in front of the secretary of
defense for approval from the president
this is a memo prepared by the most
senior leaders in the U.S military some
of the most powerful men in the country
and they're asking for permission to
execute a plan a plan to lob mortar
shells into their own military bases
with some damage to installations and
then to make hijacking attempts against
civilian air and surface craft they're
proposing to blow up a U.S ship in the
U.S naval base Guantanamo Bay and even
to conduct a terror campaign on American
soil exploding a few plastic explosives
and carefully chosen spots
we're looking at a plan to blow things
up on American soil and then to blame it
all on Cuba Cuban people have not yet
[Music]
operation never happened but it almost
did and that gets to a big question why
would some of America's most powerful
leaders charged with safeguarding our
nation think that their Duty would
require them to lie to and terrorize the
American people
in other words why were they planning
operation northwards we did not the
first time the Communist tanks have
rolled over
again rain is not inexhaustible
before we dive into today's kind of
insane video I need to thank the sponsor
who I'm very grateful for think you
better help for sponsoring today's video
for three years maybe I've been in
therapy and I can say it has truly
changed my life it has changed my mind
it has changed how I see the world and
I've become a huge fan of therapy as a
very very important part of my happiness
betterhelp is a place that makes therapy
more accessible to people using
technology is a platform where you sign
up you fill out a quick survey and you
get matched with a therapist they have a
huge network of tens of thousands of
licensed therapists and you can start
therapy in as little as 48 hours and you
can choose how you do it you can do it
as a phone call or as a video chat or
even as texting the beauty about this
model is that it doesn't bind you to the
therapists who are available in your
local geographical area and it makes it
so easy to schedule your therapy to
change your schedule or even to change
your therapist for free finding a
therapist can be hard and emotional and
difficult and better help makes it
easier for you so if you are somebody
who wants to try therapy out betterhelp
is a fantastic way to try it and see if
it could change your life as much as it
has changed mine because they sponsored
today's video they're giving 10 off the
first month for my audience who tries
out better help there's a link in my
description it's betterhelp.com Johnny
Harris thank you better help for
sponsoring today's video Let's dive back
into operation Northwoods
[Music]
operation Northwoods was a response to a
problem the U.S government had they
called it the Cuba problem
Cuba became a problem for the CIA when
they watched this young activist with an
affinity for cigars lead a Communist
Revolution on the island throwing out
the American friendly dictator and
nationalizing all the valuable land and
industries that American businesses had
been getting rich off for decades this
was the Cold War and communism was now
90 miles away threatening to spread to
other countries in Latin America
countries that American businesses also
wanted to continue controlling and
exploiting and any day this new leader
could align with the Soviet Union giving
the US's biggest geopolitical rival a
military base within breathing distance
of Florida
so this was what the Joint Chiefs called
their Cuba problem
[Music]
us had a few solutions to their problem
first they put an embargo on Cuba
blocking all U.S exports to the country
except for food and Medicine second they
stopped buying Cuba's largest export
sugar this actually ended up backfiring
when the Soviet Union stepped in to buy
Cuban sugar kicking off an economic
alliance between these two communist
countries exactly what the U.S didn't
want and third the U.S started making
plans
[Music]
lots of plans plans to somehow get rid
of Castro to turn Cuba back into the
American Business friendly client State
through whatever means necessary in one
of the secret plans called operation
Zapata the CIA recruited 1500 Cuban
Exiles who fled to Miami during the
Cuban Revolution it was this little
cia-funded army called Brigade 2506 and
the goal was to have them invade Cuba
and remove Castro from power so the CIA
trains them at this camp in the
mountains of Guatemala where they had
just recently executed a coup and
installed a US friendly dictator and
right in the middle of the planning
stages of this operation JFK wins the
presidency
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country and he inherits this scheme
to invade Cuba using exiled Cubans the
CIA briefs him on it this plan to fix
the Cuba Problem by forcibly unseeding
Castro using Cuban Exiles and after some
debate JFK approves the plan
so on the 17th of April 1961 they
launched their Invasion Brigade 2506
landed on Playa giron with the plan to
invade the island and Spark a popular
revolution against Castro
leadership of Fidel Castro Landings were
affected by rebels at several but it was
a complete failure Castro had found out
about the invasion ahead of time a radio
station on the beach had spotted the
invading ships arriving and called for
help several of the invading ships sank
on the coral reef and the invading
forces were met with immediate
resistance from Cuban Armed Forces who
defeated them within three days most of
them were captured nine U.S servicemen
actually flew combat missions in support
of this Invasion four of which were shot
down and killed in the process something
the U.S government and the CIA would go
on to deny for almost 30 years but the
point is that this Invasion failed
miserably and JFK and his administration
were to blame
on traditional military needs on armies
prepared to cross borders on missiles
boys for flight
now it should be clear that this is no
longer enough JFK would later fire the
CIA director holding him responsible for
the disastrous Invasion plan that we
know as the Bay of Pigs but this didn't
change anything the US government was
still obsessed with removing Castro from
power they just needed a new plan so JFK
initiates his own plan called the Cuba
project AKA operation Mongoose over the
next year the CIA employs hundreds of
spies to collect Intelligence on Cuba
they send submarines on recon missions
to Cuban Waters they fund anti-castro
protest movements spreading propaganda
throughout the country they sabotaged
Cuban infrastructure to create chaos and
they make dozens more plans to
assassinate Castro directly including
preparing poisonous pills to be planted
in a beverage to be drunk by Castro they
even hired the American Mafia to deliver
the pills knowing that the mafia had
their casinos kicked out of Havana
During the Revolution and would want
revenge but none of this worked the
assassination attempts all fell apart
Fidel Castro still remained in power his
support wasn't wavering and the U.S
military was getting desperate they
needed to solve the Cuba problem before
the Soviets could get more involved on
the island so after all these botched
assassination attempts and failed
invasions The Joint Chiefs of Staff
concluded that the only way to get rid
of Castro was for the U.S military
itself to invade Cuba and take him out
but they knew that the U.S public would
not support an outright invasion they
needed to create a reason a
justification and this gets us back to
our document
the one that went to the Secretary of
Defense for the president's approval
this cover and deception plan to make
attacks on American targets fake attacks
that will be blamed on Cuba to raise
tensions between the U.S and Cuba to
justify an invasion a legitimate
provocation as the basis for a U.S
military intervention in Cuba
in other words a lie to the American
public in the International Community a
series of false Flags to get what they
wanted and all detailed in this
classified document that was only meant
for a few people with hopes that the
president would approve in the spring of
1962.
if the nations of this hemisphere
should fail to meet their commitments
against outside communist penetration
then I wanted clearly understood
that this government will not hesitate
in meeting its primary obligations
which are to the security of our nation
so let's see what this plan actually
says it starts with the U.S military
base at Guantanamo Bay where they would
start rumors using fake radio stations
and get american-friendly locals to
Stage fake attacks on the base starting
riots in the surrounding area another
proposed part of the plan was to blow up
a U.S ship and blame it on Cuba this was
specifically called out as a quote
remember the main incident referencing
the sinking of an American warship in
Cuba in the late 1800s that the U.S used
to justify intervening in Cuba back then
to fight the Spanish this is often
thought of as a planned sabotage to
justify the intervention and here was
the U.S military in the 60s at it again
the document predicts that the
newspapers would start reporting on the
casualties causing a helpful wave of
national indignation they also wanted to
create a fake terrorist campaign on
American soil in Miami or Washington
they wanted to sink boats of Cuban
refugees and Stage the shooting of ref
Refugee targets and even suggested
exploding a few plastic bombs in
American cities these weren't all going
to be pretend they even say in the
document that they would go to the
extent of wounding people and then
making fake arrests with prepared
documents so it could all be widely
publicized making Cuba look like an
irresponsible government worthy of
American intervention they thought
through having American Air Force pilots
fly over places like Nicaragua and drop
bombs on Cane fields to burn them down
using weapons from the Soviet Union but
for this to work they would have to be
flying Cuban military-style aircraft
they would need to ensure that their
planes were properly painted they would
also use these planes to harass American
civilian aircraft making it look like it
was the Cubans doing this they planned a
fake hijacking of commercial planes to
blame the Cuban government or to fake
shooting down a civilian airliner and if
that wasn't enough The Joint Chiefs
planned to create an incident which will
make it appear that communist Cuban Jets
have destroyed a U.S Air Force aircraft
while it was flying over international
waters in an unprovoked attack
operation Northwoods was a reckless plan
to lie and hurt people proposed by top
government leaders who were more and
more desperate to invade Cuba and they
wanted to move fast they say in just a
few months they needed to do this so
that this attack wouldn't involve the
Soviet Union who still hadn't
established any defense pact or military
bases in Cuba so what we're looking at
here is the increasing desperation of
the U.S military to achieve its goal to
solve the Cuba problem if JFK would just
approve this plan then the military
would get to work blowing things up
attacking their bases and terrorizing
the American people
but he rejected it operation Northwoods
never happened
JFK's rejection of this plan is one
reason that there was a rift between him
and the military with the military
wanting to take a hard line on Cuba and
JFK feeling the sting of the Bay of Pigs
invasion thinking that something like
this was too much of a risk a month
later another document came to him the
Joint Chiefs following up with another
memo saying that the only way to remove
the Communist Regime was military
intervention by the United States and
that Cuba was a vital base of operations
for Espionage sabotage and subversion
against other countries in the region
the fear was that communism would spread
across Latin America because of this and
time is running out
the rift between JFK and the military
continued during the Cuban Missile
Crisis when the Joint Chiefs hoped to
deploy nuclear missiles against the
Soviets and invade Cuba but JFK stood up
to the military once again and said no
JFK eventually went on to deny General
Leeman lemnitzer another term as
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
likely because of his leading role in
planning operation Northwoods and
looking at this bizarre episode in
American history you might feel like
this is a moment where our system worked
military leaders tried to abuse their
power to launch an unprovoked and
illegal invasion of another country and
the president stopped them checks and
balances right but the reality is all
these men have the same goal
Castro out of power and Cuba under their
control again their disagreement was one
of just a few degrees the means not the
ends the reality is that the US was one
man just one person away from this
operation happening from a full-scale
Invasion if JFK had lost the presidency
to Nixon would operation Northwoods have
happened we can't say conclusively but
it certainly raises the probability but
what's more startling is that outside of
a few norms and some ideas about
government nothing fundamentally has
changed in our government the political
military machine still runs on the same
software it did in the 60s if the US
government felt like it and had a big
enough enemy a big enough threat to
American interests
it could happen again
the Iraqi regime
has plotted to develop anthrax
and nerve gas
and nuclear weapons for over a decade
States like these and their terrorist
allies constitute an axis of Evil arming
to threaten the Peace of the world